I love to eat I like just about
everything and to me cuisine is really
one of the signal achievements of our
society plants play an essential role in
that process by giving us the goods the
fruits and vegetables that provide much
of the raw material for our cuisine and
yet plants themselves never get to
experience cuisine as we do and to me
that seemed always to be kind of a shame
I suppose that they should give us
something as extraordinary as they do
and not get it in turn so I started to
think about how plants might get their
own form of cuisine that would go beyond
the everyday experience that they have
of gouging themselves on sunlight if you
think about it our cuisine is simply a
fancy way in which the basic nutrients
that we need are articulated in balance
with each other to provide an
aesthetically pleasing experience I
figured that there's no reason why you
can't do the same thing for a plant
given that plants are consuming the full
spectrum of sunlight and that different
parts of the spectrum give plants
different essential elements in their
diet so I started to look at some of the
leading cookbooks by Julia Child and
others and trying to reverse engineer
from those cookbooks the various ways in
which different ingredients work
together the way in which different
foodstuffs that are necessary for our
sustenance are put together to transform
them into cuisine at the same time I
started looking at sunlight and the way
in which different parts of the spectrum
are essential to plants and plants
respond to different parts of the
spectrum in different ways and then I
started to map the one on to the other
in order to make a photosynthetic
cuisine a photosynthetic restaurant for
plants the idea was to build a meal that
the plant would experience over the
course of the day by filtering sunlight
through colored filters where the order
in which different colors were exposed
to the plant would be the cuisine that
would have all of the nutritive value
that the plants would get were they
exposed to the full spectrum for the
entire day but would put those nutrients
in relationship to each other in a way
that would have a sort of culinary
satisfaction in addition to simply a
metabolic satisfaction so in the case of
a comfort food for plants or a French
sort of style cuisine in a continental
cuisine what I can do is I can take the
sunlight that occurs over the course of
the day naturally where it moves from
more in the red to more in the blue
range and then back again and I can
increase the redness and the blueness
and I can make it so that it's a more
extreme version of what happens in
nature or I can switch it up I can make
it so that the plant is constantly
surprised and that surprise becomes in
the way that avant-garde cuisine works
part of the pleasure of the meal so I
opened a restaurant in the town of
Sacramento California at the Crocker Art
Museum out in the gardens there were
hundred year old rose bushes that had
always been gouging on sunlight just as
it came down to them from the sky had
never had a cuisine of their own
and I built some filters into the garden
that were oriented according to how the
Sun arcs across the sky so that
naturally over the course of the day the
plants get a meal that involves many
different colors and then since not
every plant can go to Sacramento in fact
they can't travel at all for the most
part I decided that plants at home
should have the opportunity to have a
photosynthetic cuisine as well
I made a TV dinner for plants that was
broadcast over public access television
in New York where you could put your
plants in front of the TV and the colors
that that appeared on the screen
provided the plants with a full meal
it's pretty weird when you see a plant
enjoying a gourmet meal maybe a little
bit off-putting possibly even upsetting
this is something that is specific to us
to our culture this is something that we
do with plants and to plants and when we
see a plant doing this having a great
meal I think that it has the effect of
taking us outside of ourselves and of
allowing us to reorient ourselves to
think about what it is that makes our
cuisine so special that makes a meal so
special and more broadly what is it that
makes our culture what it is what is it
that makes us humans is really the
question that you end up asking at the
point that you start finding
characteristically human activities
being performed by other species because
when you see another species doing
something that is so particularly human
and it hasn't been anthropomorphize but
rather has been specifically
deliberately brought into their domain
according to their needs you find
yourself sort of in a parallel universe
where you can look back on your own
world on your own habits and they no
longer look so familiar they're no
longer so routine
I think that we can do this every day
and it doesn't take putting up a bunch
of filters in a garden in Sacramento
it doesn't necessarily even take
building something literally simply the
act of contemplating the transposition
of something that we take for granted to
another species is enough to make
whatever was so totally obvious as to be
essentially invisible to us and to make
it suddenly strange enough that we can
grapple with it and that we can
reconsider it in new ways